c'était du jamais vu même en russie un
tribunal met sur pied à même un poste de
police de quartier avec ses nouvelles
nées a été amenée ici sans aucun préavis
seuls les journalistes de quelques
chaînes d'état russes étaient à
l'intérieur on n'y comprend rien a dit
l'opposant dans cette vidéo qu'il a pu
vraisemblablement envoyé lui même de la
salle d'audience c'est impossible ce qui
se passe ici c'est l'illégalité au plus
haut niveau didier alix et commence par
les sourires est tenu depuis des heures
où il a probablement passé la nuit et où
il subit une audience qui était
littéralement improvisé et dont on
attend encore de connaître l'issue
pauline a dit qu'elle est venue le
soutenir et peine à croire ce qui arrive
à son pays
il n'y a plus aucun principe de droit
pour l'instant la juge a condamné alex
navale né à 30 jours de détention
mais ce n'est que le début mais
procureur désormais qu'il passe les
trois prochaines années une mid
il ya les barreaux il avait déjà été
condamné avec source de co2
[Musique]
c'est de la répression pure et simple
pour faire disparaître l'opposition pour
de bon dans cet avocat qui avait défendu
l'homme d'affaires et opposant miral
khodorkovski condamné à 10 ans prison en
2003 c'est en train de devenir la norme
en russie dit-il
car pour l'instant à l'indignation de la
communauté internationale qui demande la
libération immédiate de navalni ne
semble pas ébranler kremlin bien au
contraire les occidentaux s'accroche à
son histoire pour détourner l'attention
de leurs propres problèmes a lancé le
ministre des affaires étrangères mais
clairement quoi faire de navalni demeure
un casse tête pour le président vladimir
poutine près de moscou
nîmes ensuite on se protège les mêmes
avant de partir pour la prison navalni
n'avait pas dit son dernier mot
il lance un appel à la mobilisation à
l'échelle du pays
sortez dans la rue samedi minéraux
connus du fait que pour vous et pour
votre avenir ici tamar altérait scorede
au canada moscou